hello there it's been a while I hope
life is treating you well fortnite's
storyline has been sleeping over the
Christmas period but today it woke up
story content finally returns to the
game we love the scientist has been
found and the rift Warden has revealed
themselves let's go over the last few
updates and see how the law is building
my Creator code is Adam Mario if you'd
be so kind let's do this
stop
finally the Christmas decorations have
left the island gone are the evergreen
trees with the gifts underneath them and
also that means crack shot's cabin has
been abandoned yet again as it is every
year before the holiday season started
we saw something happen imperative to
the story the first steps towards
something which looks like a rift gate a
portal to other worlds plans were left
on a rooftop as building began three
weeks later this has evolved to stage
two of the plan the first parts of the
Ring are in place and that was the
moment the rift Warden revealed
themselves via abrasia I'm still not
sure how this thing works it's a fire
pit plus technology equals Intergalactic
video calls I guess
into the oath bound
my task said by the Ageless Champion is
to create a stable Rift gate
Bridge
all up a minute we first need to look at
the rift warden's outfit amazing armor
with a frightening detail the joints and
shoulder straps are made from hands and
arms I don't think this person is
completely trustworthy look even the
knees are held by hands an amazing
detail it's like the skin is made from
the river sticks itself lovely
so the rift Walden is called stellen
which Google tells me is an old Swedish
word which means calm a few updates back
Amy gave stellen the refined awe we
created from the Rocks the Paradigm left
us right at the start of the season when
she helped create this New World by
utilizing the power of those glowy rocks
the oath bound plans to open gateways to
other realities stellen is in charge of
that and look he's already asking us to
do it for him and we do but this is for
another reason stellen has a secret and
to uncover it we need to gain his trust
next we are tasked with visiting the
zero point or the place we think the
zero point is under yet we aren't here
for that this is actually a planetary
chart and big Stalin needs to know where
in space we are before the rift Gates
can be opened to elsewhere
Cosmos by placing down very scientific
sensors and smacking them in order just
like a real scientist he gets the
answers he needs it appears we either
aren't on reality zero anymore or
reality zero is not where it should be
[Music]
thus we are totally BFFs right now and
that's his cue to share his big secret
thank you
I
I used
to trust if we do not finish the rift
gate the concert
will be
there is another Watcher tracking this
island a shapeless man with dark purpose
any ideas who that could be maybe
another one of the last reality they do
have a track record of shapeshifters
watching us Amy's unshort if we can
trust the rift Warden and we quietly
test his theories on reality hopping
behind his back
plan to visit slash maybe take over
other realities seem a little suspicious
to you of course this wouldn't be a
fortnight Mission without really weird
things to do so we collect a clam from
the beach a taco from the town center
and we visit crackshots cabin one last
time to pick up the last remaining
Christmas toy a little cuddle team
leader Teddy Amy places AI coding inside
those items which makes them sound like
this
[Music]
I don't know what test subject means
trust me there's less drama this way
[Music]
and now the magic happens up at the
Bastian Amy has created a small Rift
gate a teeny tiny test and we simply
Yeet all three items through it if all
goes to plan they will find the
scientist wherever he is who was
consumed by Chrome last season and then
we can reassemble the seven who were
also mostly consumed by the Chrome last
season this isn't How It Ends
everything went to plan and all the
items have returned to this reality we
just need to pick them up yet look at
them these things have changed the once
fluffy lovely pink teddy is now a husk
of dark energy like those fiends that
are summoned by the cube Queen did the
subjects find the scientist
foreign
oh so they did find him in fact they
found all the seven but they have all
changed hmm my guess would be that we're
going to get corrupted versions of the
seven now expect click bait from all
those fortnite creators for the next
three months now over to the second test
subject a taco which came back with
eyeballs it says this
[Laughter]
so the scientist is going through a fate
darker than the worst fate imaginable oh
happy jolly good times and finally test
subject number three is a clam which now
has a snowball inside
[Music]
something
this one confirms the seven and the
scientists can still be saved but by the
sounds of it they aren't having a very
nice time right now Amy sums up the next
update
we are going to help the rift Ward and
build that Rift gate and then we are
going to double cross them and use it
first to save the seven finally fortnite
storyline is hotting up with a portal to
jump to new Worlds the confirmation that
the seven are alive and the constant
threat the kingdom we are in will fall
to war at any moment we are about to
cross the oath bound I think that's
everything oh in fact there is one more
thing I promise to include today and
it's this guy Graham The Gnome is alive
and well and can be found over by the
clock tower stuck in the snow it will
probably be nothing but I still hold
hope that one day his plan for a new
gnome order will be witnessed until then
I'll keep an eye on him I'm Adam you're
awesome it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time and also a massive thank
you to anyone who's used my code over
the last month I know my content has
been non-existent I really appreciate
your support
[Music]
thank you
thank you